good morning Hank in Saturday February
15th time for a special bonus video
Willy please don't meet the tripod come
on Willy you can't you can't eat the
tripod I'm making a video no no even the
tripod oh do you just want to be in the
video is that the problem do you want to
be a YouTube celebrity and I'm not doing
a good job of blood in you so Hank today
with Willy's health and also with the
help of me from the past I'm going to
answer some questions about my new book
Paper Towns that I didn't get to answer
in my last video but I'm already boring
you are you doing any public appearances
soon yes and thank you for asking on
Friday March 13th I'm going to be here
in Indianapolis doing a reading as part
of a fundraiser for a great organization
called second story you can find out
more about that in the sidebar I believe
I'm pointing in the right direction and
then on Thursday March 19th we're going
to be an Amsterdam in the Netherlands
actually you can't come Willy but I know
you're upset about it
that's right hang I'm going to Amsterdam
for the launch of the Dutch version of
Paper Towns European nerdfighters if
you'd like to come there's going to be
an awesome public nerdfighter gathering
on Thursday night in Amsterdam I don't
know the details yet but it would be
very helpful if you would sign up link
to do that is in the sidebar how long
did it take you to write Paper Towns
stop three years you seemed kind of
rushed in the end were you yeah I spent
three years writing the book but the end
ten minutes no I wasn't rushed at the
end but I also didn't want to say
everything on the page why do you love
road trips as they appear in two of your
three books
well first off road trips are fun and
secondly they're just a really really
good metaphor Lily I'm trying don't know
it's when I'm trying to talk about
metaphor why'd you call it on Nixon area
and not Wikipedia a lot of people ask me
about this and they seem to think that I
was worried that Wikipedia might sue me
but of course no one in all of human
history has less standing to sue anyone
for anything than Wikipedia I wasn't
worried about that I had my fancy
literary reasons omniscient Airy you
know contains all of the knowledge is
the girl on the cover a nerdfighter I
don't know all I know about her is that
she's a nice young woman from Canada
what about other countries it's out in
Australia now although apparently
someone hard to find and it's coming out
in a bunch of other countries but it
isn't out yet either there are
Brotherhood 2.0 references in Paper
Towns or there are Paper Towns
references in Brotherhood 2.0 which is
it it's definitely that there are Paper
Towns references in Brotherhood 2.0 many
of you spent the last year and a half of
the writing and revision of
four towns with me which meant that
inevitably in the way that friends do
you were going to be exposed to things
that I was thinking about and wondering
about while I was writing Paper Towns
you should do more collaborative writing
are you now soon please yes I am now
soon please my next book which comes out
in the spring of 2010 is a
collaboratively written book with my
friend David Levithan will you ask Hank
about the Carrie Bradshaw punishment
yeah Hank to Carrie Bradshaw punishment
you need to do it now soon please Hank
past me currently in bubbles the
nerdfighting puppy would all like to say
best wishes and you'll see me tomorrow